thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with the men of the hour fabiano caruana
the new american cup champion
congratulations fabiano and tony is
going to present you with the champions
trophy that's right so uh as i mentioned
with our interview with irina um you
know it's just amazing to host the
american cup for the first time we look
forward to bringing this event back year
after year and really i couldn't have
done better uh with the great commentary
team that we have here christian yasser
yasser excuse me
you guys really um
do an amazing job of not just making it
exciting and fun but also educational uh
something that we can all learn from so
thank you all very much for the hard
work you do and fabi i mean
congratulations nothing nothing more to
say really uh you had a an outstanding
dominant performance and when i'm the
organizer i can have preferences so
congratulations uh we have a beautiful
tiffany uh and company bracelet here uh
sterling silver that we'll have engraved
with your name the year of the event uh
as well as the event logo thank you tony
congratulations
and also congratulations to you tony for
choosing this very new and exciting
format it gave us all trills and spills
it was exciting thank you very much
thank you and fabiano i want to ask you
first of all you had a very difficult
event at the beginning that match
against jeffrey sean you are on the edge
tell us how you leave that one and after
that it was just smooth sailing for you
if i like it well i wouldn't call it
entirely smooth sailing every match was
very tough i mean
uh you know this match could have gone
very differently especially yesterday
but i think i took my chances at the
most critical moments um even in the
early matches even against jeffrey i was
i think i was fighting well uh despite
you know the ups and downs uh but i i
wasn't surprised that uh none of the you
know none of the matches were easier
than others despite uh obviously there's
some favorites in this tournament and uh
but all the players and especially the
young guys you know are underrated and
and fully capable of playing with the
best players in the world so
i i didn't take any match slightly i
mean especially after i played jeffrey
and then i played sam who had just
beaten wesley it's it's not like you had
any any easy players here but uh yeah
i'm extremely extremely pleased with how
it all went tell us a little bit about
this final match against a good friend
of yours uh levon aronian when you found
out that you're going to play him after
their finals in the elimination bracket
against lanier how did you prepare
psychologically as well as over the
board
well i didn't do anything really
different or special
i mean i
i wasn't concerned about let's say going
to tiebreak so i wasn't trying to push
too hard like today i didn't i didn't
play an especially
you know crazy a risky opening it was it
was quite a quiet affair for most of the
game i thought that uh you know if we go
to to play off again then it'll probably
be 50 50 but uh
but i have two chances and he only has
one which are pretty good odds for me uh
so i was trying to keep my cool uh i
mean i was just mainly happy that i
didn't have to you know
fight for a win just to stay into in
this match because yesterday uh i really
was on the verge
as uh the candidates tournament is
approaching you're getting this
confidence booster from this tournament
your white pieces specifically worked
very well how do you feel about that
um well it's always good to play well i
don't really
like think of it as terms of you know
that i'm in good form before the
candidates that it will mean i
necessarily play well in the candidates
i mean the the one time i i won the
candidates i had my most atrocious
result ever right before that and the
the last time i played the candidates i
had my best result ever and i i didn't
do very well in the candidates i had my
best results ever in viking's day before
that and it didn't help me in the
candidates so i don't really you know
buy into that thing of like form
carrying over um but anyway it's very
good to play well and especially to win
a tournament with so many of the world's
best players and uh also on on american
soil it's great to win an event fabiano
caruana the new american cup champion
thank you christian and our
congratulations most especially to
fabiano he didn't lose any matches like
arena crush he went through